[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour
votre émission dédiée à vos idées
sorties tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 24 novembre
l'histoire plus vivante que jamais ce
week end à versailles nouvelle édition
du salon du livre d'histoire
histoire de livres romans et bandes
dessinées plus de 150 auteurs sont
attendus
le commissaire du salon nous parlera
plus en détails du programme des
festivités le regard on s'en sert tous
les jours mais comment fonctionne-t-il
50 ans et qui nous apporte quelques
éléments de réponses en sa nouvelle
exposition à parcours entre art et
science à découvrir jusqu en mars et
bientôt noël alors pour patienter
jusqu'au 25 n'oubliez surtout pas votre
calendrier de l'avent à notre
rendez-vous junior mélanie va nous
montrer comment en créer un avec des
chaussettes une idée ludique à faire en
famille top départ de la 17e édition de
la fête du conte à saint quentin en
yvelines une cinquantaine de spectacles
sont proposés jusqu'au 10 décembre dans
le réseau des médiathèques de
l'agglomération et les lieux partenaires
laissez vous conter histoire les gens de
comptines jeux et récits en tout genre
et ça s'adresse aux petits comme aux
plus grands comme nous l'expliquent la
coordinatrice de l'événement au micro de
mélanie poquet c'est pour tout le monde
c'est pour tout le monde
bien sûr il ya une dimension il ya une
dimension pour le jeune public qui est
assez assez importante sur cette
programmation fait du compte mais il ya
des poteaux 6 pour les adultes et mêmes
les contes pour enfants on peut se
laisser seul et c'est tout à fait
prendre et voyager à voyager avec avec
nos enfants sur sur ce festival
si vous êtes en panne d'idées cadeaux à
la proche des fêtes pourquoi ne pas
favoriser les petits artisans et les
créateurs locaux chez capsule market à
versailles ils sont nombreux à vous
faire découvrir leurs créations
la plupart sont uniques et jusqu'au 23
décembre c'est aussi l'occasion de
découvrir une exposition d'aquarelles
sur le château de versailles et ses
alentours du potager du roi aux écuries
royales
l'artiste michel du voisin présente ses
oeuvres et son livre des séances de
dédicaces sont prévues les 2 et 9
décembre
il nous a parlé de son travail et coûté
un peu au jardin j'étais sur place mais
dans le château bien évidemment je n'ai
pas plus je pouvais pas y aller puisque
vous n'aurez pas permis de mettre mon
cheval est donc j'ai fait beaucoup de
photos j'ai retravaillé la première
photo c'est un peu plus compliqué bien
évidemment mais pas plus difficile
chaque chaque matière les marbres et
tous les tissus faut aller chercher
et ça c'est ce que j'aime bien faire
donc c'est un peu ma spécialité
[Musique]
et on reste à versailles car ce week-end
se déroule la nouvelle édition du salon
du livre d'histoire
histoire de lire des rencontres des
débats et des animations sont prévues
jusqu'à dimanche 26 novembre les équipes
travaillent d'arrache-pied pour que tout
soit prêt dès samedi mais le commissaire
du salon a quand même réussi à nous
rejoindre pour nous en parler bonjour
vienne est malin bonjour cabine et je le
disais grosses réparations car il s'agit
de la dixième édition
alors c'est vraiment un événement qui
est devenu incontournable aujourd'hui à
versailles est très attendu écoutez je
confirme effectivement on avait commencé
tout petit en 2008 donc avec françois de
mazières le maire de versailles etienne
de montety qui préside notre notre salon
mais le bébé a grossi effectivement on
espère peut-être ce week-end plus de
vingt mille personnes des passionnés qui
viennent de versailles mais des yvelines
et peut-être même de toute l'île de
france
alors qu'avez vous prévu pour ce pour
cet anniversaire alors le programme se
densifie donc outre la présence de ces
150 auteurs qui sont là en dédicace en
permanence il ya une programmation
effectivement j'avais dire toutes les
minutes il se fasse quelque chose soit
l'hôtel de ville soit l'hôtel du
département
par exemple on multiplie les les
rencontres mise en scène c'est à dire
des comédiens qui aiment venir en
costume des extraits d'un livre par
exemple monsieur darcos ancien ministre
va avoir un virgile encore en corps et
âme costumés qui va venir dire des
extraits et il me disait l'autre jour
c'est bête j'ai patauge dans mon dans ma
garde-robe je serai genre erwin moi
aussi de me déguiser leur mettre une
également et donc vous allez accueillir
aussi des invités exceptionnels vous
vous en avez cités 1 milliard également
eric vuillard prix boncourt 2017 et
olivier guez prix renaudot 2010 est oui
alors ça je lirai ans
on suit peut-être une tendance une mode
de l'édition effectivement quel roman
historique
on peut embrasser l'histoire de façon
très sérieuse avec des essais donc
effectivement philippe contamine est
manal de maresca des grands historiens
sont re là mais il y aussi une première
façon si on n'a pas l'habitude de lire
l'histoire c'est effectivement via leurs
romans historiques et donc il y aura
aussi plein d'autres romanciers qui
seront qui seront là et notamment ceux
ces deux grands prix prestigieux qui
nous font l'honneur d'être là et de nous
parler de du de la montée du nazisme de
cette période là donc plus de 150
auteurs présents mais également un
espace dédié aux plus jeunes aussi vous
avez oublié les enfants non non non les
enfants 7 heures les cherry on l'est on
les aime
donc effectivement
on va parler de d'antigone la courageuse
on va parler un grand jeu sur les les
rois de france quels sont les dix plus
grands rois de france donc voilà bd des
énigmes voilà donc toute la journée dans
notre tente et un chapiteau qui a dédié
vraiment à la jeunesse entre l'hôtel de
ville et hôtel du département sur
l'avenue de paris en face du château un
grand espace dédié aux enfants
c'est très important parce que l'idée
aussi cet événement c'est de rendre
l'histoire assez accessible pour le
grand public et surtout montrer que
c'est très vivant vous l'avez dit
notamment avec les communes de faire les
personnes en costume qui vont lire des
histoires aussi c'est notre c'est notre
souhait on a cette passion on pense que
l'histoire c'est important ça fait
partie de notre notre culture et les
français comme les anglais aiment
l'histoire
donc effectivement lorànt deutsch nous
aime beaucoup il va revenir cette année
pour nous parler de ses pérégrinations
dans l'est dans les rues dans les rues
de paris
voilà il ya nicolas caraux qui est un
journaliste aussi de radio qui vient de
sortir un livre sur les sur les héros de
la littérature
qui en fait on pousse une réalité
historique derrière des grands
personnages ils se cachent derrière le
commissaire maigret il ya eu vraiment un
commissaire qui a inspiré l'oeuvre
littéraire voilà c'est c'est plein de
choses qui fait que effectivement même
si on n'est pas des gros lecteurs
d'histoire on a une raison d'être de
venir ce week-end à versailles on parle
d' histoire avec un grand h mais on
devrait dire plutôt des histoires en fin
de compte absolument elles sont
multiples variées elles et elles ne sont
pas finis ont continué à écrire cette
histoire et les moments forts du
week-end alors si on devait en donner à
un ou deux en exemple c'est difficile
parce que la programmation est très
riche mais peut-être voilà vraiment des
évènements à ne pas louper
c'est effectivement très difficile on
est très fiers d'avoir le général pierre
de villiers qui sera parmi nos dimanches
je pense à une belle aventure bd puisque
aussi beaucoup d'auteurs de bande
dessinée historique
je pense effectivement à marc jailloux
qui a repris le flambeau de jacques
martin avec un nouvel épisode des
personnages alix voilà et puis peut-être
un coup de coeur pour un jeune
un jeune historien de de 20 ans qui
transmet lui l'histoire pas forcément à
travers le lit mais dans un premier
temps à travers l'image comme vous donc
à un jeune youtuber qui vient de faire
un très beau film sur oradour sur glane
et donc il a été interviewé des
personnes âgées de ce visage qui n'avait
jamais accepté de témoigner
donc voilà brandon var être projettera
un film à l'ugc demain à 14 heures et
ensuite y aura débat avec des historiens
d'accord donc à ne pas louper donc au
cinéma l'histoire aussi au cinéma du
coup avec ce salon tout à fait merci
beaucoup viennent et malin de nous avoir
dévoilé la programmation de ce 10ème
salon du livre d'histoire de versailles
alors on le rappelle les visiteurs sont
attendus pour un véritable voyage dans
l'histoire à l'hôtel de ville et à
l'hôtel du département l'entrée est
libre et ça commence à 14h merci vianney
ma lentille comment fonctionne notre
oeil qu'est ce que le regard une
exposition à la commanderie des
templiers d'elancourt nous invite à
plonger dans l'univers de la perception
et de l'illusion
mais annie poquet nous fait découvrir en
images ce parcours entre art et science
[Musique]
cette exposition elle a été conçue
pensés et réalisés dans le cadre de la
saison culturelle à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines objectif image
la question que nous nous sommes posée
c'est qu'est-ce que voir qu'est-ce que
regardez donc ce monde où nous sommes
entourés d'image on a une partie
perception qui est dans la chapelle et
une partie illusion qui est dans le
bâtiment regardons nous sommes
actuellement
[Musique]
qui a tout ce qui concerne la partie
illusion d'optique donc de la chose la
plus simple à la chose la plus
compliquée et ensuite vous avez toute
une partie sur la réalité virtuelle
la réalité augmentée pour la partie
artistique
on est sur la notion de rendre visible
l'invisible
on a une offre qui a été coproduite par
donc la commanderie et l'artiste 9
d'eric verne qui s'appelle rvb 255 et
cette oeuvre là en fait donc capte notre
image et prend le prétexte de notre
image et du coup rend visible à la fois
la lumière sur nous et en même temps
c'est le prétexte pour montrer la
bataille des couleurs entre le rvb rouge
vert bleu
[Musique]
dans la partie scientifique on va partir
de qu'est ce que c'est l'oeil
qu'est ce que c'est voir et puis sur la
partie installations artistiques
nous avons décidé de prendre un parti
pris un point de vue d'un co et
d'explorer l'oeil écoute à la fois vous
avez des petites cartel qui vous
explique les choses et à la fois il ya
un côté manipulation est donc un côté
ludique et autant les enfants que les
adultes
ça fonctionne très bien on se laisse
prendre faut se laisser d'ailleurs il
faut se laisser prendre
c'est l'idée
[Musique]
dans un mois c'est le réveillon de noël
c'est parfois un peu difficile de
patienter jusqu'au jour j
on peut donc écrire sa lettre au père
noël décorer son sapin et surtout le
rendez vous incontournable du matin
ouvrir une case de son calendrier de
l'avent mélanie vous aider si vous avez
décidé d'en fabriquer un avec la
matériel original certes avec des
chaussettes alors on a tous des
chaussettes qui se retrouve tout seul à
cause de la machine à laver qui fait
disparaître la copine ou parce que cette
fameuse copine s'est abîmé est pas
question d gtc kelly on peut toujours
s'en servir donc il nous en faut 24
il faut aussi un petit peu de matériel
quand même un peu de maths et avec
quelques petites choses parce que pour
pour un pour info pour cette activité je
n'ai rien acheté tous les éléments je
les avais déjà dans un malade d'activité
j'ai pris de la peinture des pinces à
linge de la colle des mouchoirs une
aiguille du fils et des étoiles que j'ai
imprimé et une fois que tout était
rassemblée j'ai choisi une chaussette
blanche neutre pour la rendre plus juste
plus jolie j'ai choisi de la dea
correcte des étoiles puisque avec des
ciseaux j'ai découpé une des étoiles que
j'avais imprimés et avec de la peinture
j'ai fait une première étoile en faisant
le contour et on peut aussi faire des
étoiles plein en se servant de la
feuille comme un mouchoir
mais on peut aussi découpé coude
récollets enfin un constat en forme
quand on peut laisser libre cours à son
imagination que c'est ça hier 24
chaussettes donc on peut faire un peu
tout ce qu'on veut pour la 2ème moi j'en
ai choisi trois de chaussettes une kim
sert de base et deux autres dont j'ai
découpé les détails sur une chaussette
noire j'ai trouvé des petits rectangles
de coup là je trouvais millions donc
j'ai donc isoler cette partie que j'ai
ensuite cousue sur ma chaussette marron
qui est autiste tout tristoune et pour
la décorer un peu plus on va le voir à
l'image là j'ai plutôt choisi de
récupérer la décoration hello kitty
d'une chaussette pour enfants que j'ai
aussi collé dessus et pour celle du 24
décembre alors une déco un peu
particulière oui c'est le dernier jour
d'attentes avant que le père noël
décembre par la cheminée
alors j'ai choisi moi de faire mon
propre papa noël en chaussettes
rien de plus simple une chaussette que
rouge sur laquelle j'ai collé des
morceaux de mouchoirs déchiré vous posez
vous pouvez aussi oser le faire avec du
coton des yeux et on est dessiné au
feutre et voilà le père noël et pour
former son calendrier
alors des chiffres écrits sur du papier
donc le tout accroché à une corde alors
on va essayer de le montrer sans faire
tomber
voilà donc ça donne ça voilà le
calendrier de l'avent tout petit peu de
place pour l'installer sur le mur oui
forcément ou au dessus de la cheminée
voilà que ce sont les chaussettes de
noël merci beaucoup
mélanie pour votre calendrier de l'avent
donc prêt à être installé dès la semaine
prochaine puisque la semaine prochaine
ce sera le 1er décembre
donc n'oubliez pas de le fabriquer ce
week-end merci beaucoup mélanie le 7-8
loisirs est maintenant terminé merci de
nous avoir suivis j'espère que vous avez
fait le plein d'idées pour vous amuser
en famille ou entre amis je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro et je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
m